So far we are focused largely
on message confidentiality.
What if we want to protect
message integrity.
That is, we want to prevent or
detect any unauthorized
modification to the message.
One standard approach is to
send the last block of CBC,
also called a CBC residue,
along with a plain text.
Now, if an attacker
intercepts the message and
modify the plain text, the attacker
does not have the correct key, therefore
he cannot compute a correct CBC
residue with the modified plain text.
So he's forced to resend the modified
plain text with original CBC residue.
The CBC residue that the receiver
computes on the modified plaintext
will not be the same as the CBC
residue that he receives.
Therefore, the receiver would know
that the plaintext has been modified.
In other words, the CBC residue provides
a protection of message integrity.